one of the things you've heard me say
many times on the show if you've been
watching or listening for any period of
time is that we're just genuinely really
bad at predicting recessions some people
have been predicting a recession for the
last five years
some have been saying it's six months
away others it's twelve months away
others it's eighteen months away and
we're really just terrible at predicting
when the next recession is going to be
but one of the things we do know is that
we are one day closer today than we were
yesterday to the next recession that's
just sort of a reality unless you
believe that something so fundamental
has changed that there will never be a
recession again and if you're making
that case I I'd love to hear why that's
what you believe
number two we do know that there are
certain signals that we can look at that
will tell us whether we are imminently
closer to a recession we're still not
very good at predicting the future state
of the economy at any particular point
in time
but we actually increasingly have
indicators that suggest we are getting
closer and closer to the next recession
the latest being that the yield curve
has inverted if you have no idea what
that means fear not I am going to
explain it to you hopefully in terms
that will make it clear to everybody
even if this is not in your educational
or or personal interest background so
don't worry about that but before we get
to that some of the other signals we've
seen recently that are of concern
there's one that doesn't get a lot of
attention but it is important which is
that the number of people the percentage
of people who are 90 days or more behind
on car payments has been going up up up
and this is really important because it
seems sort of innocuous and as esoteric
in some way 90 plus days behind on car
payments what does that tell us about
the state of the economy car payments
and car loans tell us a lot about the
degree of financial stress on people
because to fall thirty days behind on a
car payment because you had an
unexpected expense okay to fall 60 days
behind okay but when people become 90 or
more days behind on car payments
cars that they presumably need to get to
work and earn money that they need to
get their kids to school or whatever
else the case may be that starts to be a
red flag about the personal financial
situation of many many people in the
United States that's been a red flag
number two the stock market aratus ISM
as a result of Donald Trump's trade war
including basically the markets being
back down to where we were a year and a
half ago does not bode particularly well
for the future of the economy and then
now yesterday the yield curve has
inverted what does that mean and why do
we care if you don't understand it it's
hard to see it as a red alert so let's
try to dig into it so we can all
understand what I'm talking about in
general in the world of money in order
to potentially earn a higher and higher
return you either need to accept more
risk the risk of losing money or tie up
your money for longer periods of time so
if you look at CDs a certificate of
deposit you can get with a bank or
financial institution if you're willing
to lock your money up for a year you say
take my money I can't touch it for a
year you might be offered a two percent
return on your CD these are hypothetical
numbers by the way but if you're willing
to say I will lock my money up for two
years you can in principle earn a higher
return maybe it's a three percent return
instead of a two percent return because
you're giving up access to the money for
a longer period of time this is the way
things typically work because if you
were able to earn two percent on a
one-year or a two-year CD most people
would pick the one-year CD because it's
a shorter lock up period so along the
same lines normally when you look at the
ten-year US Treasury bond the interest
rate yield on that is higher than the
yield on the 2-year US Treasury bond
basically for the same reasons that I
just discussed there's now been an
inversion of the yield curve where the
ten-year US Treasury bond briefly and
this fluctuates all the time had a lower
yield than the two-year bond this is a
marker with a very strong correlation to
risk
if you look at the last seven recessions
going back to 1969 all seven were
preceded by the ten-year bond yield
dropping below the two-year bond yield
and as you might remember the Fed
recently lowered rates with the idea in
part of keeping the ten-year bond
yielding more than the two-year US
Treasury bond but the continued chaos
with the Chinese trade war that Donald
Trump is waging and other things have
been an opposing force and indeed the
10-year yield has dropped below the
2-year yield so why does this matter so
much the 10-year Treasury bond is
considered a very reliable safe haven
for investor money the ten-year bond if
you believe in the general future
stability of the economy is a very safe
place to put money when the ten-year
bond yields less than the 2-year bond it
signals that there is a very negative
outlook about the future of the economy
in the next few years
why because investors are so scared
about the 2-year outlook that they
prefer to take the guaranteed return on
the ten-year bond even if it's less to
such a degree that it ends up bidding
down the yield because it is seen as
safer and more favorable for traders and
for markets and for the economy and it
effectively creates a feedback loop
where because of the lower yield banks
become less willing to lend money which
further causes an economic slowdown and
like much of this stuff these feedback
loops go on and on and on and who knows
where they stop so understand a few
things number one none of this changes
that the economy doesn't work for tens
of millions of people in the United
States maybe even hundreds of millions
that's understood I'm still a Social
Democrat I'm not jumping into finance
bro mode or anything like that that's
one thing to understand number two we
are always heading to the next recession
the question is when and number three
increasingly the indicators say that
it's going to be soon and we actually
know of specific Trump policy that's
pushing us closer think back to 2012
before the 2012 election Obama versus
Romney they both made claims about the
economy the reality was that
indicators were pretty good at the time
and the economy was likely to remain
pretty good no matter who was elected
president in 2012 I said it at the time
it remained true we now actually have
white house policy that is specifically
precipitating the next recession led by
the disastrous trade war and we are
starting to see more and more indicators
of that I want to hear from you let me
know what you think and we will
certainly do a follow up and continue to
keep an eye on that yield curve